thank you for taking the time today I
know you're really shooting a show all
day and you've got your family but I
mean just first how are you doing um we
listen we're all doing great because you
know everybody in the family as well and
we cannot complain I can't complain
you know cabin fever yes getting a
little edgy with each other yes you know
it would love to go walk around a
shopping mall for an hour but that'll
happen
yeah so what are you doing to sort of
burn off some of that cabin fever from
time to time
um I go into my bedroom and sulk that's
the real answer everybody else is like I
go to the gym I do this I make it crappy
no wait I wish I could say I do a lot of
cooking or doing crafts or something no
I just go in sulk or have another bath
you know I probably had three baths a
day out of boredom nothing wrong with
that there's nothing wrong with that now
when you talk about family how is Ozzie
doing I know he was getting ready to do
a really important treatment in
Switzerland and you talked about yeah
and unfortunately you know we you know
Switzerland closed all the borders so
we'll get there though you know
hopefully we'll be able to get there
later on in the summer but no everything
had to be put on hold but he's doing
good he's in good spirits he's doing
good thank you that's amazing and really
hopeful with everything they're doing in
Switzerland with that yeah yeah Indus
crossed everything crossed absolutely
for sure so are you able to see your
grandkids how are you keeping because I
know you're such an involved grandma how
are you keeping connected with the
kiddos just over FaceTime that's it
that's as good as it gets right now and
it's really sad
some days I I don't like to do it
because it makes me really sad mm-hmm
because I can't hug them and you know
actually be there with them but it's you
know it's challenging and I think you're
not the only one my daughter doesn't
like to FaceTime
it makes her really upset she's sick and
to FaceTime her grandparents she doesn't
want to do it I just think it's that
feeling of you can see them but you
can't touch them and it's very confusing
you know very it's it's it makes it
worse or new it really does I get it
totally mm-hmm so how are you aside from
having baths and going into your rooms
okay what are some other things that
you're finding that you love doing right
now I'm just eating I am a couch potato
I have like I'm gonna start sprouting I
am just eating and eating again out of
boredom you know yeah no I think that
what's one of the first things you'll do
when when we all get released outside of
our houses oh my lord just to be able to
go in and and sit in a restaurant and
have good conversations with friends and
just just to go out and be silly
yes might you invite Harry and Megan
over I would love to I wonder how
they're doing in LA I mean imagine just
moving from Canada straight to there and
then all of this happens I know but at
least she's got family and a lot of
friends you know in LA so it's good it's
gonna be easier that way to be with your
mom and everything yeah no absolutely
you're doing the talk right now remotely
which looks incredible and it's amazing
how are you finding doing the show and
is there anything specifically that
you're really enjoying right now that
you didn't expect I
yet to be able to come to work with my
pajama bottoms on and just in a top you
know it's like a
that is very enjoyable listen I hear you
I know I haven't worn high heels in six
weeks and it couldn't be happier
oh my lord do you know what my daughter
and I I'm right there with you my
daughter and I were talking about it we
were saying do not miss those heels one
bit mm-hmm I was clearly doing I did see
on the show one day you know she broke
down and was saying she just missed you
so much you guys are so close how is she
doing
Kelly's doing good she's doing good she
um you know she's been doing a lot of
walking she's out everyday walking I
know five miles a day she's not good ah
that's amazing yeah it's hard when you
know when you're you're that close and
you can't be with your mom or be with
your daughter that's that's incredibly
difficult it's terrible it's just
terrible but you know what it's like I
keep saying we're all going through the
same thing mm-hmm know for sure
you've got some really really great
guests on to that I mean have been such
good entertainment for all of us can you
tell us about some of the new ones that
you have coming up in the next little
while oh my lord who do we have coming
up Mary Steenburgen yeah and Donnie
Wahlberg yeah I know he's great they're
all lovely people we're so blessed
because most of the people have been on
multiple times that we talk to so it is
like talking with a mate you know they
just come in and and it's just very
natural and it's it's that's the gift of
doing a show like ours you know you you
make all these great new friends yeah
well you can definitely tell by the way
just this show blends together it's so
easy to watch and just you feel like
you're sitting with a bunch of
girlfriends and getting to know what's
going on so you guys do such a good job
at that really thank you another great
surprise was the kids and I were
watching the masked singer and then you
were on there incredible
I hear there's a cult many people are
wanting you to like be a regular there
loving that oh gosh it's such a great
show and you know the the all the judges
the hosts are all brilliant everybody on
the show and you know I've worked with
Nick before Nicole before and so it's
just fantastic and then to work with
Jenny who I adore it was just it I'm
like is this really work amazing it's
just like a fun day out it was great I
remember when we ran into you in in
Niagara Falls I think it's the last time
I remember spikes and you were talking
about just all these wonderful things
that have been happening with you
professionally and it's been incredible
and it's it's just continued the sieges
of really great opportunities met with
great timing um what does it feel like
for you we know when we're watching it
from the outside in it's just it's an
incredible journey but what does it feel
like for you um just you know I think I
told you when when we met then that I
just feel blessed totally blessed you
know I have no complaints with my life
I've been very blessed very lucky very
loved and I couldn't ask for more I just
couldn't I'm there is nothing that I
need I can't say god I really need to do
this or I really want this in my life I
am fine right where I'm at more than
fine so if you could look ahead say five
more years is there anything
professionally that you really would
like to do that you haven't done yet um
I said before Christmas that I wanted to
do more theater but I did theater at
Christmas in in London and it exhausted
me so much I don't want to do any more
fine forget I ever said back forget it
and he's fine where I